hey youtubers is Charlie so these are
going to be my Korra book 4 predictions
the good news is is that Mike and Bryan
said that pretty much every major
character in storyline are going to get
wrapped up by the end of book 4 as of
right now there is no official release
date but plan for summer next year until
they say otherwise it's going to be
available in all the same digital places
it is right now like Nick comm for
instance so you will be able to watch it
for free but let's get going so these
gonna be my top 10 predictions careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episodes yet I'll wait just a sec ok
number 10
there will be no Korra at San Diego
Comic Con next year mostly because
they'll probably release it before then
but the second big reason is because
they barely spent any time or energy
marketing it this year and they've
already written the cost of producing it
off like they've already paid for all
the episodes to be made so why bother
spending extra money to rent out
ballroom 20 and bring the cast out so if
you wanted to do a comic-con panel or
get a booth on the floor it costs a lot
of money so it's a big expense Mike and
Brian basically said during the book 3
comic-con panel that they expected it
would be their last time at San Diego
comic-con but they will be going to New
York Comic Con this fall that's October
9th to the 12th I'm not going to be
there myself but I will be doing videos
for any big stuff that they make
announcements for so if you're going to
New York comic-con that might be your
last chance to ask them core questions
unless they do comic book panels in
future Comic Cons so on to number 9
before is going to be the last avatar
series on television and there will be
no animated movie but it will continue
in the comics like the comics will keep
going Mike and Brian said that they were
pretty fried on the Avatar universe
after spending the last 10 years of
their life working on it they will
continue to develop new shows probably
animated shows but it will not be avatar
related so the big asterisk there is
that you know this is Hollywood so
nothing is confirmed until it's
confirmed
someone could always back a dumptruck up
money up to them and they could say ok
we'll do a little bit more really it's
up to Nick they're the ones that own the
rights and it's unlikely that they're
going to produce new Korra material the
comics are totally going to keep going
though they're way easier to produce and
they have a lot more freedom with the
stories that they can tell there's also
the video games that are coming out
right now and depending on the success
of those there will be more I know
everyone wants to see avatar series like
for the rest of time but break basically
laugh at that idea he said there's no
way that that's going to happen which
actually leads me
number eight book four is going to end
in a way that will allow the Avatar
cycle to continue even if it's not on
screen there's nothing in any of their
writing or belief systems that have led
me to believe that Korra is going to be
the last avatar ever the whole idea was
a major plot point for the book 3 finale
so here thought that the world did not
need an avatar anymore but Tenzin
clearly states evidence as to why they
need an avatar more than ever the line
will continue it's just that we don't
know if Korra is going to live to see
old age but I'd like to see whether or
not they choose to do it is for the
final scene you know to be something
close to avatar Juan's final scene in
beginnings like where Korra is dying in
old age in the middle of a battle or
even just in her home with her family
and we hear a baby cry out as she fades
away
it'd just be a way to confirm the Avatar
cycle is continuing it's the world still
needs an avatar it would be nice to see
a flash-forward or at least some sort of
acknowledgment that Korra got some of
the things that she wanted in life but I
totally understand if they choose not to
do something that explicit sometimes
that's way too on-the-nose and it's more
effective to just imply that the cycle
will continue regardless of what's going
on in the world the whole idea of the
Avatar series is like the circle of life
it's like this big continuing cycle you
have harmonic convergence raava and
vaatu the hundred year war and now the
collapse of the earth Kingdom
everything gets repeated so I'd at least
like to see them ending in a way that
fits with that thumb Attica Lee but on
to number seven Jinora is going to walk
a much more enlightened path than Aang
and Korra ever did I don't think they're
gonna copy and paste Aang's character
development onto her even though she
looks a lot like him in the finale but
she is a child burdened with the
leadership of the air nation so you
can't help the point - Aang the
difference is is that she has eggs high
level of spirituality with Cora's
gung-ho attitude so she has like all
their best qualities if you guys have
ever come across any of Frank Herbert's
do novels it's like the Golden Path it's
like Jinora is the one meant to walk the
golden path the series is definitely
positioning her to be the next non
avatar world leader like she'll be the
new Iroh of the series and probably go
on to lead the White Lotus along with
the air nation for the rest of her life
avatar yang Cheng the female airbending
master is probably the best example of
what she might end up looking like
but number six all the major characters
that are still alive are going to come
back that includes Katara Zuko
tov any of the team and characters that
are still alive it's possible that they
could assemble because of all the chaos
that's to here caused the major conflict
is going to be the revolution that the
Red Lotus tried to start so here did say
that it started but technically as far
as we know it's only going on in the
earth Kingdom right now as cool as it is
bringing all those Last Airbender
characters back I think that they'll
still just use them in a supporting role
like the way they use Zuko this season
just like in a very minor role there are
so many unanswered questions about where
Toph and Azula have been since we last
saw them but because break said that
they tie everything up I think it least
means we'll get answers
maybe not the answers we want but
something is better than nothing but
moving on to number 5 course ami is
still totally gonna be a thing I know a
lot of you asked me my thoughts on
course ami I do have a few thoughts I
love the two of them together but I
don't think there's anything sexual
going on as much as tumblr wants it to
happen
they really just wanted korra and asami
to have like positive female friends
that had nothing to do with their
relationships even though they
technically do have motto in common
really he's the only one at this point
that's still weird about their kind of
shared love triangle but with all the
chords been through I'm expecting Asami
to stick around and help take care of
her until she's fully healed
speaking of which during last airbender
if you remember in the beginning of book
3 egg basically had to heal the avatar
spirit by reconnecting with his past
lives naturally Korra is broken so she
has to heal herself but she also has to
heal her connection with her past lives
I know they have reckoned a lot of
things because at the time that the Aang
episodes aired Mike and bride hadn't
incorporated the idea Bravo vaatu and
avatar wanted the series of they were
really only a handful of avatars that
Eng had to reconnect with but one
possible solution for court to heal that
connection with those past lives is yang
Chen's festival which she gets you guys
excited for number 4 Korra will
reconnect with her past lives I know
Mike and Bryan did an interview after
book 2 saying the Korra would continue
to be cut off but I think it's possible
that they could have just been talking
about book 3 the ancient festival method
comes straight from the rift part to
that comic book that was written by Mike
and Bryan and it was published last
month like literally last month so it's
way more current than those earlier
comments that they made it's possible
that whenever they say the core was
going to be cut off for forever that we
were just taking them to let
like they were trying to tease something
and we just misinterpreted it but what
does yank Chen's festival this is
actually where it gets more exciting
it's an air Nomad festival started by
avatar yangchen the female Airbender
that I said that Jinora is going to
resemble so the airbenders are back now
just like Jinora said in the finale so
naturally they're probably going to try
and bring back yang Chen's festival
which of course gives Korra that back
door for reconnecting to our past lives
yang Chen basically started the festival
is a way to uphold the treaty with the
ancient spirit of old general Iroh it's
not the uncle Iroh that we know someone
who is way way older but the festival
continued after her death as a way for
the air nation to honor her achievements
so they really don't go into the physics
of how yang Chen's festival helps you
know the Avatar reconnect with their
past lives but I'm just gonna take them
at their word but number three none of
the previous villains are gonna make a
big reappearance in book 4 like they're
not gonna be a big part of the problem
so here is not going to escape and be
the big bat again Boone Locke in a mon
are dead and the Red Lotus is still
around but I don't see them being the
big bad I think the real villain is just
going to be the chaos itself in the air
nomads
yes Tenzin said we'll just travel from
nation to nation to help make things
really Zen again also really important
we have to remember that vark is
developing high speed rail and I think
that's going to have something to do
with bringing all the nations together I
think part of healing the world is
bringing it closer together and the
fastest way to do that is to create
high-speed transit it's at the advent of
the Internet just making the whole world
smaller it's like because of the
internet I can post a video on youtube
about avatar and instantly all around
the world everybody can watch it at the
same time so I think the Jinora and the
air nation will be like the spiritual
solution and vark is going to be the
practical solution plus if he can
establish a monopoly on shipping he can
get even richer which sounds like
something he would totally do he gets
rich and gets to help people
although the part about helping people
he probably doesn't care about so much
he'll take whatever you can get but
number two things are going to move
closer to a worldwide democracy the
nations will all continue to be separate
but I think the things that soohyun
talked about while they were still with
the metal clan will start to spread like
her ideas that deals for equal
representation so when you look at all
the nations of the world like all the
bending tribes really like the last
holdout in terms of having a monarchy is
the Fire Nation right now which is
basically where Zuko's daughter comes
back in I'm into
to see how she reacts to the idea of
democracy thus far in the series the
fire nation has been conspicuously
absent with the exception of Zhu Crowes
grants on arrow he's a general in the
United forces so technically the fire
nation did not contribute any help in
books 1 & 2 or at least that we saw so I
think they didn't book 4 you know we
might see them trying to convince the
Fire Nation to be more like England in
real life the royal family in Great
Britain passed a lot of their
legislative power onto the government
nowadays the royal family is more of a
figurehead in the day to day job of
running the country falls on the
government
so maybe the Fire Nation will start
moving towards this but on to my number
one prediction Azula will also be back
she hasn't been confirmed dead and the
last time we saw her was during the
search comic and she was traveling with
team Aang she was still totally nuts
but just like Toph I at least think that
we'll see her in a flashback think of it
as like a Harry Potter thing it opens at
the close I feel like all the big
characters will be around in the final
moments think about it this way you
start with everyone together then
circumstances push them apart all over
the world and then eventually
circumstances start pulling them back
together by the end of the story
logically the way for Mike and Bryan to
closed the avatar book would be to bring
the old characters and the new ones all
together again I feel like that's the
perfect situation but of course the
alternative is that you know all-out
mass hysteria and war could bring
everyone back together to Azula could
totally try and seize on all the chaos
as a way to assert the throne she does
still have a legitimate claim and at
this point she's a bit younger than Zuko
so he's a pretty good fighter which
means that she's also probably still a
pretty good fighter would it not be
totally awesome to see like old Azula
and old Katara just go at it with each
other I don't think that's going to
happen but it would be totally amazing
but let me know what your predictions
for book for are and do you think that
Toph and Azula will reappear and do you
think the core is going to reconnect
with her past lives so there's a whole
lot of stuff going on this weekend I'm
working on an avatar Q&A I'll try and
post that tonight but I'm also doing a
Doctor Who episode 1 review today so
Doctor Who is coming back just as Cora's
leaving so be sure to check that out too
I'm doing a giveaway for a couple more
weeks for poor but I'm also doing a
Doctor Who giveaway so even if you don't
like Doctor Who you should check it out
but right now click here to get my Korra
Q&A I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and click
to get my finale video thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]